President Trump appears to be ready to
shake up his national security team CBS
News confirms that type White House
aides have signed off on a plan to
remove Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
his most likely replacement is CIA
director Mike Pompeo Tillerson is
scheduled to have lunch at the White
House today with the president and
defense secretary Jim mattis mr. Trump
declined an opportunity to end the
speculation about Tillerson yesterday
chip Reid is at the White House with
more on the timing of the personnel
overhaul chip sounds like it could be
awkward today at the White House good
morning oh yeah it's good morning the
White House insists that a plan for a
replacement is not imminent but the
relationship between the president and
his Secretary of State has certainly
been strained for quite a long time and
now we are told that a plan is in place
and that it's been approved by chief of
staff John Kelly president Trump
officially rang in the holiday season
and a new year may bring big changes to
his cabinet mr. president
Rex is here Tillerson was at the White
House Thursday and the president
suggested that meant his Secretary of
State was still on the job his
spokeswoman dismissed rumors that a
change was imminent when the president
loses confidence in someone they will no
longer serve in the capacity that
they're in but CBS News confirms there's
a plan to put CIA director Mike Pompeo
at the State Department replacing him
with either retired Vice Admiral Robert
Harwood or Arkansas Senator and Trump
loyalists Tom cotton I'm proud to be
representing the people of Arkansas
would you like to be CI dress I'm very
proud to be representing the people of
Arkansas cotton denied that he was
looking for a new job but the president
has disagreements over foreign policy
with his Secretary of State who for
example opposes the president's desire
to recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel
and the handling of tensions with North
Korea boiled over just a few weeks ago
that came after reports that Tillerson
has become frustrated with the president
and had even referred to him as a [ __ ]
I have never considered leaving this
post the reorganization would continue
the president's trend of appointing
former military officers to powerful
administration posts Harvard is a former
Navy SEAL and cotton was an infantry
officer in Iraq and Afghanistan
bianna it'll be a fly on the wall at
that lunch today chip thank you